John all right native style 6 37 back to
school for the Clark County School
District for students at Southeast
Career Tech sector it's also back to the
kitchen the restaurant there opens today
giving teenagers a taste of The Culinary
World Candace Charles is live this
morning in our Newsroom with more on
this cool program and how you can get
your child involved as well Candace good
morning good morning good morning folks
it is the last stretch to get your
students in the culinary program at
secta staff will be looking at thousands
of applications this month for the
2022-2023 school year helping local
students jump start their career in a
booming industry here in Nevada now the
Whitney gives 9th to 12th graders the
opportunity to learn the front and the
back of the house about 150 students
work as chefs servers and busers
offering a one-of-a-kind fine dining
experience at the high school and giving
the next generation of the food service
industry a jump start on their career
it's really exciting to see their growth
as the year continues it's like no other
experience because it's not like this at
other schools but it's fun to see like
friends serve your food
and the price of student staff approved
as is the food and that's according to
the patrons that's what they told me
folks so the culinary program students
tell me the real life experience gives
them the confidence they need to apply
for jobs at Walden high school and go
for a career in culinary when they
graduate and dropping that they're a
sector graduate certainly does help now
if you want to get your student on this
career path apply today applications are
open now for 9th and 10th graders
students are accepted on a lottery basis
admissions will close in the next two
weeks so we got those details for you on
our website newsnow.com